l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono parigi
sono emozionato perché stiamo per
giocare a knock out siti che un gioco
che avevo già tenuto d'occhio fino al 30
maggio è possibile giocare gratis su
tutte le piattaforme in cross play la
cosa piga di questo gioco e che tipo
dodge ball ma molto più figo si gioca
tipo death match ci sono varie mappe io
giocherò oggi con il thomas nazionale al
tv che è sempre presente quando c'è
bisogno di spaccare i delle tani il buon
step ne è il sottoscritto formeranno una
squadra di tre persone e faranno eco
leggi e leggine acquistavano l'ho ancora
mai fatta praticamente ci sono dei
condotti che ti portano dalla parte
opposta cambiata ma come fai a saperlo è
perché ho visto dei video stamattina tu
quanto sai tra yard a te ma basta
premier
vabbè raga buttiamoci di sotto abbiamo
perso
[Musica]
ok subito lancia mi fanno male
ma lei non so se gli o colpiti e non
credo non ne sono fatti niente nice
eppure i soldi ci sono stati in faccia
non sono arrivate anche loro come me ne
vado io come faccio a schivare questa
cosa ragazzi non corro abbastanza veloce
forse centro l'elemento più grosse
percorrere ok bellissimo in malissimo
occhio mai ma ha fatto veramente un culo
quadro con la chigi e veniamo da un
ormai fra tre ma rilancia la palla
siete come prendiamolo prima facendo sul
successo provino l'ho tirata probabilità
occhio che sta qua hanno questo e quello
morto che niente scherzi sono sulla sua
sinistra
bravissimo è ok
niente nella sera di partito fratello
come stai
come andiamo oggi all'asta e colpito
alla madonna raga grandissima azione
questa pro gaming ggv pia e sport oggi
conosciamo ultimo anno un solo testo sia
la venerazione 3000 ok l'ho colpito non
hanno colpito ma poi l'ho capito non
appunto mikasa stagione e così si
giocano nazione dice moderna erano false
let's go and brothers bellissima ragazza
è piaciuta look e l'inizio
trasformandosi in palla non è male sono
sento c'è una palla vediamo il condotto
oddio cosa è minuta ma destra eccoli qua
e là visti i tre donne
lanciano faccio io sono state occhio che
ti prendo tutte e due
grande effetto e no fermo uno schema
come è scappato ma se non la lancia
subito perderlo fine però c'è la
velocità il pugilato colpito colpito
vino doc è morto ciò attraverso andata
andato andato rom in 26 su di lui era
impossibile che scriva 30 laga
attenzione questa gente col a destra lo
so io ho capito mammamia tom le giocate
giuste
c'è un processo 2 quando farai ha
sfoggiato incredibile colpiscilo cominci
a salvare l'uomo morto da miss a neymar
ma sembra merda
possibile ma non ci arriva siamo 5 1
pronto bambino non ha colpito bloccato
di solito mi sta aiutando che non cade
risalto le scuole scuole scolpito aia sa
cosa qua qualcun'altra miliziani raga io
li appendono colpito l'effetto l'ho
colpito effetto da un malore e non a
valle
ok 4 occhio a casa brevissimi amo
distruggendo andiamo io canto era una
guardia morto 82 ragala pazzesco la
prima rissa questa 400 che è successo
per ora niente male vero
qualcosa novak ai ragazzi va bè va certo
quando si vince è staccare la
connessione sempre facile così facciamo
dei templi sono di troppo il braccio dal
ma andiamo ai mondiali in polonia
madonna ragazza è bella partenza abbiamo
ancora giocato e siamo ok ok ok non male
però ragazze avevo solo siamo solo
portico di stupidi perché per adesso di
sta facendo il culo è
e morto in tutto questo secondo me se ci
riserviamo questo non è andato giù alla
capi qua non arrivano più
non so come zapata studente morto chi
non ama tutti l'abbiamo vista avevo una
bella bomba hanno tutti 16 giocatori
arrivati con il buco pitrolo dietro
c'entra un cazzo
no mai a praga 45 fattibilissima
arrivare una volta se si sta spostando
due labbra uno qua di volare basta una
palla bellissima tom bravo bravo carcere
occhio mi sta mirando lo so chi non lo
scriverò mai la schivata ha preso me ok
colpito nice
oggi sono tutti una vita 4
colpito tutti della vita tutte la vita
un è morto due morti
questo che manca o ok raga
se volete volto scusa la vita qui da ssd
tu ti lanci marine fans away pure cadute
nel vuoto
nice madonna ragazzi disastro lancio
quando neanche un prefetto se vai o
colpito quello parte bravo madonna raga
dopo i ko 7 a 0 stiamo facendo disastri
questa incredibile c'è nessuno e te non
solo e sono no peccato che noi a
cambiare la palla e con quella che c'è
per terra da ma nel dubbio la piscina
pochi o che si sta lanciando arrivo di
marivaux sono volte aveva niente questo
è morto nova schivata all'ultimo lo
potrebbe risolto dai e non muore solo
attivando a buttare di sotto ma nessuno
muore e morto a volte volta ma porca
vacca che botto presa 94 dai ragazzi da
in un colpo solo da ragazzine e malto
ies ha lanciato al suo compagno libero
come poi sono espresso non sposo a caso
davvero fa sapere che anzi questo era
anche knock out city werder riforme è
incredibile c'è però un altro episodio
perché è stupendo niente quindi fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate fatemi sapere se
volete altri video sul mio caos city
io billing attraverso visto il video
cosi come mi piace scrivere a canale è
come sempre appunto ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]